so okay that's talking about alien life
out there in the universe
but you've also earlier in the
conversation mentioned uh
the shadow biosphere so is it possible
that we have weird life here on earth
that we're just not
like even in the high assembly
formulation of life
yeah that we're just not paying
attention to we're blind to
like life yeah potentially able to
detect but we're blind to
and maybe you could say what is the
shadow bias sure sure yeah the shadow
biosphere is this idea that there might
have been
other original life events that happened
on earth um that were independent
from the original life event that led to
us
and all of the life that we know on
earth and therefore
there could be aliens in the sense they
have a different origin event
living among us and it was
proposed by a number of people um but
one of them was uh paul davies that i
mentioned earlier as my mentor and i he
has a really a cute way of saying that
aliens could be right under our noses or
even in our noses
with a british accent it sounds better
but um but uh
but anyway so the idea is like it could
literally be anywhere
around us um and if you think actually
about the discovery of like viruses and
bacteria
you know for a long time we didn't they
were kind of a shadow biosphere it was
life that was
around us but invisible um
and but this takes it a little bit
further in saying that
you know all of those examples viruses
bacteria and everything that we've
discovered so far
has this common ancestry in the last
universal common ancestor of life on
earth so
maybe there was a different origin event
and that life is weirder still
and might be among us and we could find
it
we don't have to go out and stars live
for aliens just here on earth
do you think that's a serious
possibility
that we should explore with the tools of
science like this should be a serious
effort
i think um yes and no um and
i mean yes because i think it's a
serious hypothesis
and i think it's worth exploring and it
is certainly more economical
to look for signs of alien life on earth
than it is to go
and build spacecraft and send robots to
other planets and that was one of the
reasons it was proposed is
well if we do find an example of another
original life on earth
it's hugely informative because it means
the original life is not a rare event if
it happened
twice on the same planet that means it's
probably pretty probable given
conditions are right
so it has huge potential scientific
impact not to mention the fact that you
might have like biochemistry and stuff
that's informative for like medicine and
stuff like that but
um but i think that the thing for me
that's challenging about it and this
really comes from my own work like
thinking about
um life as a planetary scale process and
also trying to understand
sometimes what i call like the
statistical mechanics of biochemistry
but large scale statistical patterns in
the chemistry that life uses on earth
there are a lot of regularities there
and
life does seem to have planetary scale
organization
that's consistent even with some of the
patterns that we see at the individual
scale so if you think life is a
planetary scale phenomena
and the chemistry of life has to be sort
of um
not just it's not an individual is not
necessarily the fundamental unit of
life right the fundamental you know life
is these uh
informational lineages and they're kind
of you know they intersect
over spatial scales so everything on
earth is kind of related by the
common causal history yeah so it's hard
for me
based on the way i think about the
physics and als also
some of the stuff that my group has done
to really think that there could be
uh evidence or there could be a second
sample of life on earth but i think
there are ways that we need to be more
concrete about that
and i have thought a little bit about
like um
you know like you can represent the
chemistry in an individual cell as a
network
um and then those networks something my
group has shown
actually scale um with the same property
so ecosystems have the same properties
as individuals as
planetary scale and then you could
imagine if you had alien chemistry
intermixed in there that scaling would
be broken so if there's some robustness
property or something associated to it
and you get alien chemistry in there it
just breaks everything and you don't
have
a planetary ecosystem functioning
um an individual's functioning across
all these scales so
i guess what i'm arguing is life is not
a scale dependent phenomena it's not
just
cellular life so if you have a shadow
biosphere it has to be integrated with
all of these other scales in it
and that and that would lose the meaning
of the word shadow biosphere
i think so yeah so so i it's an open
question right and
i think it would it would tell us a lot
so there has been very minimal effort of
people to look for a
shadow biosphere but then the question
it could be possible that
uh there's like sufficiently distinct
planets within one planet meaning like
environments within one planet
yeah like i don't know i've been looking
uh recently
because of having a chat with catherine
declare about io the moon of jupiter
that's like all volcanoes and volcanoes
a badass but like yeah
imagining
[Laughter]
imagining life inside volcanoes right
like yeah it seems like sufficiently
chemically
different like to be living in the
darkness
right where there's a lot of heat and
maybe you could have different earths on
like a planet yeah or like if you go
deep enough in the crust
maybe there's like a layer where there's
no life and then there's suddenly life
again and maybe those
you know lizard men or whatever they
know that people dream about are really
down there
um i know that's a little flippant but
but really like there could be like
chemical cycles deep in the earth's
crust that might be
alive and are completely distinct in
chemical or origin to
surface life right that there wouldn't
be interaction with each other yeah and
that's one of the proposals for the
shadow biosphere is like sometimes
people talk about it as being
geologically or geographically distinct
that it might be
you know you have no life for this
region and then a different example
and then sometimes people talk about it
being chemically distinct that the
chemistry is sufficiently different that
it's completely orthogonal or
non-interacting with our chemistry it
seems to me at least the chemistry is
a more powerful boundary yes
than than than geographic it just seems
like
life finds a way literally to travel
yeah yes
you